ich bin wie die überschrift einer
powerpoint-präsentation 24 und ok
erreicht
es ist mal wieder soweit herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einer weiteren
episode in lübz ist hart sich an der
plätze episode luca - 2.0 war für zwei
tage in den deutschen youtube trends auf
platz eins und die bewertungen bevor es
in die trends kam sagen so aus und jetzt
sehen die bewertungen so bevor wir hier
mit den luca - anfangen würde ich sagen
schauen wir uns doch erstmal einige
kommentare an die unter das video
geschrieben wurden nachdem es in den
youtube trends auf platz eins war die
who an opfer luca was man wenig diesen
typen hasse er hat wirklich voll die
scheiße community ist so dumm wirklich
und du bist auch nicht lustig dummer
ahlmann du bist scheiße krass schwul
desel figaro hund aber zähne weiß stabil
ja da weiß man was für leute denen
youtube trend unterwegs sind
aber hier gar nicht mehr lange um den
heißen brei herum meine damen und herren
ich will kommen hier heute zum ersten
mal was passiert wenn man an einem
pfannkuchen erstickt man krebs beim
ersten ihm und ich habe jetzt schon kein
bock mehr wie nennt man einen matrosen
der sich nicht wäscht mehr richtig
leiten wir dagegen laden und stoßen
direkt weiter vor ins nächste
was macht ein arbeitsloser schauspieler
er spielt keine rolle
ok wirklich auch diese collage von
meinem bild finde ich super germany's
next topmodel könnte auch in einem
kindergarten gedreht werden jeder lernt
laufen und alle fünf minuten weint
jemand dass das stimmt an alle jungs die
eine freundin suchen stellt euch bei
ikea in die deko abteilung die frauen
nehmen da jeden scheiß mit das wird zu
mir passen denn ich bin scheiße wer hat
auch früher die sonne oben als dreieck
in die ecke gemalt jeder oder nicht
schreibt mir mal in die kommentare ob
ihr die sonne als drei gehen die ecke
das kann ja noch diese krassen kunst
leute die sie dann auch mal die rund und
dann in die mitte vorbild damit alles
erläuterte dass mein hund findet alle
meine kleider toll wenn ich ihn frage
wie ich in dem kleid aussehe sagt er
immer wirklich habe vorhin einen alten
vokabeltest gefunden deutsch stattfinden
englisch to find ist city wer hat euch
in euren humor geschissen
was ist deutschland ohne die eu gipfel
ist es ein verdammter ernst jule wie
lief die arbeit mit dem sekundenkleber
luca sekundenkleber weil meine hände
finger einmal gedacht super weiter
geht's menschen die gleichzeitig zwei
treppen stufen auf einmal nehmen sind
faul und fleißig zugleich ich will es
nicht sagen aber es ist die wahrheit
man sieht sich immer mindestens zwei mal
im leben außer menschen denen man etwas
geliehen hat das ja ihr wisst was es ist
ich bin wie die überschrift einer
powerpoint-präsentation 24 und verein
mit meiner jogginghose bin ich ungefähr
so oft joggen gegangen wie ich mit der
küchenrolle in die küche gerollt bin
lustig
jule dicker was fährst du für einen
krankenwagen luca 23 rettungssanitäter
hey wollt ihr mich verarschen dieser
moment wenn dir nach einem
streitgespräch ein passender konter
spruch erst 15 minuten später einfällt
dass es immer so
es ist immer so und man führt auch
diskussionen die nie stattfinden werden
immer in der dusche was ihr das auch
oder bin ich menschen nicht gesund
ziemlich abstoßen ich war mal in einer
band namens die brausetabletten aber wir
haben uns auf geländen wer hat dem wird
das gemacht luca punkt idiot dass die
tür alle elf minuten verliebt sich ein
pringle über paar chips
ok also da muss man wirklich erstmal
drauf kommen wenn ein waschbär viel
trainiert ist er dann eine waschmaschine
seid ihr noch zu retten wie nennt man
einen bekifften asiaten suite damit kann
ich das hier drin lassen jeder dritte
mord ist eine beziehungstat ich single
aus sicherheitsgründen ja das einzige
witzige hier an ist tatsächlich auch
wieder meine fresse ein anderes wort für
kfz mechaniker auto korrekt aber gar
nicht
ich bin heute morgen am spiegel vorbei
und dachte mir musst abnehmen gerade
erledigt spiegel ist ab ok also ich
denke mir halt ziemlich häufig hey jetzt
haben wir den tiefpunkt erreicht aber
dann kommt ein neues team und wir haben
einen neuen tiefpunkt von daher würde
ich sagen schon mal provisorisch dass
wir mit dem niveau nicht noch weiter
sinken können komme ich jetzt auch schon
zum letzten nehmen und zwar genitiv ins
wasser weil es da tief ist das heutige
video will mal wieder gezeigt dass wir
die community die bescheuerte auf der
ganzen welt ist an der stelle wird das
heutige jetzt allerdings auch beenden
wenn er lieben freunde wenn euch dieser
dritte teil luca minus gefallen hat das
unbedingt einen daumen hoch unter diesem
video hier da und schreibt werden in die
kommentare
ob in einer woche teil 4 rauskommen
sollen falls ihr in die nächste folge
luca - kommen wollte ladet eure -
einfach auf instagram hoch und verlinkt
mich dort laser luca einfach auf dem
foto markieren und dann kommt ihr
vielleicht in die nächste folge es
müssen auch nicht unbedingt - sein die
beispielsweise so aussehen sondern es
kann noch nie um seinen die so aussehen
also jetzt muss ich irgendwas mit
texteinblendungen seien die könnte auch
kreativer sein wenn ihr wollt aber
[Musik]